no problem Tony we are live welcome
everyone to another episode of rent cafe
right now for now it's just me and Mac
and Tony the black credit guy waiting
for some other people to show up if they
show up but I just wanted to welcome
everyone I want to get started because
we don't want to run too late and this
is episode 26 of rent cafe and in this
one we're going to be talking about the
truth about anime conventions and
because anime north is coming up not
this weekend by the one right after and
I'm gonna be there goes and is going to
be there
Matt Kalon is going to be there Briggs
from old anime is going to be there
vector Maximus is going to be there
we're all gonna be there and Tony you
said you're going to a convention as
well so we thought that we would have a
rental table we're talking about anime
conventions the truth what to expect the
good things the bad things the really
hot and humid things which is what
usually happens all that fun stuff you
only how are you doing wait can you hear
me yeah right
mice can you hear me yeah everyone can
hear you are you good cuz my the green
bar wasn't showing anyway I was saying
'hey you earlier cuz you said haughty
human man that's probably my least
favorite part about conventions but I'm
doing good um sorry I'm not on camera
I'm using my phone right now for this
review that I have to upload because uh
a certain female otaku uploaded a video
featuring yours truly and we have this
whole plan that I would release a review
that coincides with it in it hasn't gone
up yet so I'm waiting waited patiently
them ago see alien company I like how
you say that as if Sloan is watching us
right now and you want to guilt-trip her
no no no I'm the one guilt tripping
myself the video that she made was up
it's been up for five hours now
oh I'm the guilty party I'm the captain
I fear yeah I hear but yeah people are
asking how come is just Tony X animatic
in this one well the other people are
supposed to be showing up they're
running late it seems however until then
the big dogs are running the yard so
that is why it's just you know unique
and corny everybody else you got us
the best sexiest anime vloggers there is
I don't think anyone's gonna argue with
that I don't know there's a lot of cheap
it's out there do you know that they
just walk away Kim but let me go into
the convection can we talk about that
[ __ ] video that [ __ ] uh that guy
you know that guy you'd the one he made
which one I'll did that animes long oh
yeah I'm not saying the name but you
know what I mean yeah his name is not
enemies thought his name is Petros but
yeah when you want to talk about the
[ __ ] was that video man the one the one
where he featured Grand Cafe I was III
both was laughing and confused
well yeah that enemy snob makes like
eight videos a day so it's you know he's
always doing stuff but basically if you
guys didn't know that enemies not made a
video where he took part of rank of
favor we were talking about
slice-of-life anime luckily against me
particularly against me yeah
and he he made a video where well it's
because Tony you told you said he was an
idiot or something so then he wanted to
you know get back at you
but basically was Tony saying that
slice-of-life anime not people call it
sly so nothing happens not much happens
and then Tony was like hey in life
sometimes nothing happens that doesn't
mean that we shouldn't you know have
animated feature that type of stuff so
you know just like everyday life and of
course the snob made a little skit where
he's like watering the grass and saying
oh look my life is so dramatic I thought
it was hilarious man I get I can not
laugh it's odd I thought it was funny to
say oh here Nick Graham Briggs is here
brings us here
oh hi hey hello it was hilarious sexy
hair cookie pop hey bro thank you sir I
get uh you have a nice haircut as well I
get to you all night
xiii Quora best suit just for you how do
you look years young look at all those
years of watching high school anime they
begged eh
real friends right yeah true true last
thing I wanted about a hole you know
what um
Toki took off we took our little
discussion out of context though that
was my problem with it like I get again
what he was trying to do we took it out
of context and I'm like okay well that's
nice and everyone's like you should
respond to him like no okay don't make
him the time of day all right
it's got a startup [ __ ] that I'm not
really into I'll leave that to adamak
you know he really wants me to debate
the that animates nah for some reason
and Briggs is like on board - yeah man
because I find drama funny and
entertaining I don't think it personally
no I don't care for the drama I just
don't like really wasting my time with
it either you know I will
I'll give you this it would be
interesting to have a conversation with
them I'll even of anything I think it
would be a fun time like I've talked to
him before he is a funny guy he's very
stubborn and ridiculous
but he's also funny if you don't think
I'm socially you think think I'm serious
are you going to get very frustrated
very fast well yeah definitely his
videos he takes it out of context just
to make it look funny but like the very
argument as much as I like non self
anime as well the very argument of
nothing happens is completely avoid
because if you look at literature
literary fiction is considered the most
highbrow sophisticated fiction the Nobel
Peace Prize always goes to literary
fiction
what is literary Christian fiction it's
slice-of-life fiction it's not science
fiction it's not a fantasy it's slice of
life essentially exploring human
relationships character studies all that
stuff right on a Karenina um well you
know any great piece of work out for
Whom the Bell Tolls
um by Hemingway so um I don't know like
as many books as you can name literary
fiction that's what they're dealing with
wait I'm gonna want a Nobel Peace Prize
are you [ __ ] serious no no no other
criticism isn't laughing plastic we're
gonna tear
Nobel Peace Prize the Nobel Prize in
Literature and I don't know if they if
the Tolstoy I don't know if you want to
because I think you might have lived
before the time of the Nobel Prize in
Literature I would have to google it but
I'm saying the Nobel Prize in Literature
off almost always goes to literary
fiction and Anna Karenina is an example
of a classic work of literary fiction as
is oh okay I guess Dostoevsky works by
Ascot with shell Hemingway you know all
these famous authors they write
slice-of-life essentially I'm waiting
for a Mike over what I'll see echoes Oh
for a second okay by the way everyone
just so you know next week we are going
to have the big naruto vs 1 piece
showdown we postponed it so that miss
art can join us you guys must have heard
of miss art she's a anime youtuber and
she's a big fan of Naruto so we got in
touch with her and she said she'd love
to join us she can't do this week but
she will next week so she's going to be
holding it down for Naruto along with
Lotus and we're gonna have bricks from
old anime and 2spooky holding it down
for one piece so that's gonna be an exit
I'm gonna be here moderating so yeah I'm
really hyped for that one be sure to
spread the word about the big one piece
in our tour showdown we're gonna finally
determine which anime is better for
reals and nobody cares about you
let's get this get real here for a
second alright alright one piece does
not have a leg to stand on Briggs then
what get nervous walk into a trap bridge
you need an ear call out right now
so you're sick you're tired something
man can't do this
Luffy never backs down I leave it now
because everybody's got immutable Briggs
broke nah it's uh I think with an
extreme advantage in this fight like
just being seriously yah
breaks into spooky they've already
conferred and anything they're gonna
crush it they're gonna crush it though
I'm actually excited I'm excited that
miss arts gonna be on this so it's nice
to get some fresh
but here and this our lady I don't know
what's her life shows but I thoroughly
or watching them yeah people are
wondering if soul maka said well no he's
not because he refused to defend our
route oh he's just like I just want to
come and [ __ ] on one piece and I'm like
nobody that's not what's gonna happen
you can't just go and [ __ ] on an anime
it's easier to [ __ ] on a meet-up to
defend one yourself so you have to do
both I just see you with your key an
accent like nah buddy you can't you
can't just shut up nothing honey I'm not
your Buddy Guy I'm not your guy friend
I'm not your friend buddy
[Music]
so are the best jokes in South Park York
lider what's up glider says hi in the
chat yeah um so yeah for next week
that's happening guys stay tuned for
that
Briggs how do you feel are you pumped
you and to spoof here getting round I
know yeah we had a nice little
conversation about our arguments slash
what we think they're gonna be talking
about are they gonna be thought about
friendship
of course it's Shonen but um or soul
maka within your Allison Ted I guarantee
you can't talk about character
development in one piece Oh Tony's gone
yeah Tony I'm sorry for my in and out
because he's on his phone he can't use
his laptop right now cuz he's doing
something else with it but yeah we're
gonna do it anyway I wanna Briggs have
you been to conventions before anime
convention by the way guys in the chat
let me know if you've been to anime
conventions before just let me know like
kind of like yes I have I've been to
chew up into three I've haven't been to
any just to get a little idea and then
of course we'll talk about it in greater
detail as a week ago yeah I've been to
only one other convention I'm into anime
North and I'm super excited for Adam
into it this year
crept up on us yeah true anime north is
coming not this weekend about next
weekend which is crazy because I
remember I we bought the hotel rooms me
and goes in like 11 months ago so it was
like yeah believe it is already creeping
up on us but uh uh and also where we
have a panel confirmed that I registered
about anime and philosophy so
to be a panel at any North we're going
to talk about philosophical influences
and themes in anime like who and log-on
killa kill Code Geass right is going to
be awesome and they approve that panel
it's going to be at noon on the Sunday
at anime North so if you are going to
anime north be sure to go to that you
can come and chat with us about
philosophy is there anything better I
think not
that's so awesome that you magic at a
panel yeah I registered like months ago
so it's like a trade of a long process
but yeah it's it's a you have to like
write a proposal and justify why you
think and then you also have to have
enough interest for people to actually
want to attend so yeah that one got
approved and we'll see for the other one
I haven't heard back yet but the other
one the code yes one right I also wanted
to do a special cumbias panel as well I
think oh he could join the please beam
what's up havoc yes it an uproar but it
said havoc for a second it was a mine on
our mind a lot it doesn't have it where
the [ __ ] am I what is the stream what is
a Panama fans of the world
my name is havoc nobody I decided to
join his havoc for some reason I don't
know I just fell in love when you when
you join us tower I I don't know it just
feels awkward to join us having for some
reason enemy recon have you ever been to
a convention I'm afraid not I don't know
no I want to go to London Comicon that'd
be awesome yeah that's probably huge it
oh that's the any timber corrosion yes
it's very very I wish I can go
I know but no for your answer I have not
been into the convention I want to go
though well we're gonna school you know
on reanima conventions and we are
pleased that who have gone to a bunch we
have sukoshi Karzai says he's been to
every ax
I think that's anime expo right every
year since 2013 and isn't Anime Expo D
biggest in North America the biggest
convention North America and then anime
North is the second correct me if I'm
wrong but I believe that's the case
shot dose has been to a gaming
convention by the way what up shot dose
soul Marcus saying some [ __ ] he's not
even pay attention what I'm saying is
just like chatting people in a chat stew
early will I seek are we gonna sorry go
ahead brick notice saying someone in the
car superseded cause they said you gotta
save up money for conventions and yeah
you spent a lot of money also I
recommend limiting yourself like I'm
gonna limit myself to like a certain
amount of money going in because you
could drop major cash to the convention
oh yeah you gotta be discipline it's
almost like go into the casino because
when you go to a convention like you
will see stuff that you never knew
existed that you want to buff it's crazy
because you go to like the big vendor
area because every conventions gonna
have a big vendor area and they're gonna
have all your products there so like
every anime store in your region or even
online stores all these people are gonna
come physically there and try to get you
to buy stuff so you're gonna see you're
gonna see stuff like Gurren Lagann flags
that you're not not gonna not buy you're
not gonna not buy that flag you got to
see like adorable stuff like this you
know you're gonna know you're gonna buy
this anime knows what I'll buy it
I've a question is there gonna be a
stance specifically for boku no pico
well that's that's interesting thing
about I'll continue with this thought
because so you will see stuff you see
like posters I bought a bunch of Italian
posters for Ghibli films Ghibli films
are for castle in the sky Howl's Moving
Castle and my neighbor totoro because
the Italian posters had way better
images than the English language posted
so you see stuff like that New York damn
I gotta buy so I got Italian posters
you're gonna see body pillows have it
all sewn in I don't really need one I've
already got my waifu man but if there's
a REM one I'll definitely get it I said
you want em I sent one to you but I'm
saying you're just walking minding your
own business and then just like body
pillows like BAM and then they have like
censored stuff on them so you don't see
the boobs and stuff it's crazy so it's
just like it's it's it's like yeah same
you know limit yourself in terms of
spending money because there's so much
to buy
so much to see all in one place you see
your favorite anime you see merchandise
you see manga so much manga so much so
many DVDs blu-rays everything you could
possibly imagine so definitely limit
your budget because you could try out
you know you could go bankrupt just
there if you're an anime fan as we all
right okay I have a question as well
since like I've never been to an anime
convention but how much did I do like
these products cost and how much money
do you have to save in order to go to an
anime convention like if you want to buy
stuff how much money do you have to save
well that's what I would definitely
recommend they don't buy anything until
you've like walked around you know like
the entire area first because it like
for example I saw light novels for 25
bucks 20 bucks which is not a good price
at all you get away cheaper on Amazon
but then nothing what I found I found it
for like ten twelve dollars like light
novels so this make sure you look around
and compare prices type of thing yeah
and again it's good idea you wanna you
don't want to buy the first thing you
see because you might find something
even cooler so you let's say you see one
poster Oh
Fullmetal Alchemist York man this is
great you buy it and then you see
another even better one that you want
even more later on so it's like yeah you
gotta see everything first scope it out
and then see what you want to buy
however then sometimes stuff sells out
so that's the other problem if you see
something that you come back psycho it's
sold out so you know it's a rough it's a
rough 2k and going to cons for sure
often stuff will be overpriced to answer
your question recon however I've seen
actually on the other hand I've seen
stuff at conventions be cheaper than at
a store just because I guess like a
vendor there had really reasonable
prices compared to the store you went to
specifically also I went to the Niagara
Falls comic-con which is a small event
that it features anime products and I
found that anime North had way cheaper
anime stuff than that Comic Con in Agra
Falls so yeah so even between cons
you're going to see very different
prices so yeah if you've got to be very
very on point with that conservative
conserve yeah
absolutely any anyone in the chat have
any especially important advice so we
have recon no Pico here he hasn't been
to a con and for anyone else was
watching as Minto con guys in the child
let me know if you have some advice for
people going to conventions personally I
think that it's one great thing about
connect to this community like you go
there and especially a big con like
anime north you go in as soon as you get
there you see a whole bunch of people in
cosplay just joking around having a
great time love it all the same stuff
you long you can start a conversation
easily because you're oh you're
cosplaying is freaking calm you know I
love commenting something that so so
yeah so it's a great place to be if
you're an anime fan a great community
and then I mean or if they have so many
panels that you can attend for free so
that's another great thing like we're
getting a hosting one on Sun on the
Sunday but there's also going to be a
sole source of great panels you can
attend for free they don't charge you
anything extra to attend a panel the
only thing is you have to make sure that
you get in there on time because
sometimes the big panels are full there
fill out there's no more room so it's
not a fire hazard they won't let you in
so yep like if you really want a panel
make sure you go there early and you're
so look at the schedule look at the
timetable and go there early enough so
you can actually get a seat but
otherwise yeah I love just a whole
experience of be sure definitely if it's
hot and it's this time it's hot in most
parts of the world you know bring
sunscreen bring lots of water all that
type of stuff because if you're going to
be out in the Sun if you're going to be
waiting for a long time in lines that
it's hot as it tends to be in you know
Briggs you know how it is at anime North
sure you've got to be you got to be
prepared for that because you again you
don't to go there for an hour pay the
entry fee stay there for an hour and go
home you want to be there you're for a
whole day or for the whole weekend if
you booked guy will get a weekend pass
right so you got to you got to pace
yourself conserve your money and your
energy thank god it's cold here in the
UK cuz if you have to go and let you
said it's hot there right oh it's gonna
be so hot for out of an earth well the
thing is when you were in cosplay don't
you get warmest [ __ ] like if you're
wearing a wig or something just to fit
with your cosplaying character you're
gonna get so like you can't even if you
have to take it off or you need to go
inside but here in the UK it's cold so
you can wear it as long as you want
but here's the question what cosplay
should I wear if I ever go to a
convention oh that's a great question
recon I'll let the people in the chat oh
yes I'd love to hear the people hospira
is for recon oh because ugly ideas for
me sometimes known as we should I wear
if I ever go to a convention I want
something I want something stylish I
want something that will I don't know be
everyone who's wearing Colin I want
something to be at the top you want to
be d cosplayer you want to be a guy
everyone's like man I remember that guy
by the way anime dude says recon anime
dude says my advice to you is get me a
c2 body pillow I'll pay you back
wait what's c2 from Code Geass Huachuca
Geass watch Code Geass recon I'm
watching her the Roku's I just watch
Code Geass you know Allison Suzaku is
good anime man it's a good show you'll
be the best Agnes well d XD have that
like red arm where anima dude says he
hopes had a rapper hits a million subs
so that I have to cosplay as a maid for
enemy north well we're about nine days
away so we'll see if we can get that 1
million so you know Mike next year but
that Megan might be next year Matt never
lose hope I think I should wear a maid
outfit that's what forgotten on 15 oh
yeah I forgot not another - get up
should I wear a ram or Ram outfit blue
Ram ok Briggs you want to be around with
milk No
and we'll both be majoring no hold hands
you can even get worse actually
ANBU says you need to cosplay of course
boku no pico so I don't know who you're
a boku no pico cosplaying can you buy
whatever that twin can you actually buy
a book and a pico cosplay from and I'm
sure you can I've never tried but if you
google it ok
I'm sure you hear uh I bet the outfit is
just gonna be exposed wear it wait I'm
gonna hit gram of penguins burn read
says boys Kim jong-un always Korea theme
from angles burn read nothing is if I go
there with a boku no pico outfit I'm
pretty sure arms gonna get kicked out
sounds like [ __ ] off we don't want any
gay [ __ ] I'm gonna be firing on head
conventions at conventions you oh yeah
you have missed the cosplay from like
300-pound bearded men so you will be
fine
recon if you go smoke without people
just don't go [ __ ] naked but if you
can kind of do that [ __ ] you gonna do No
the sad thing is you could probably got
close to naked yeah yeah the outfit is
pretty much probably gonna be close to
make it I'd really want to go to like a
winter convention somewhere so I could
be Sanji and that's the only reason I'm
not being Sanji for Adam a North is
because like I would die in a suit so
I'm gonna be like Luffy like kind of
like a cut-off depe thing oh yeah yeah
so we bring some sunscreen though Briggs
oh for sure by the way we go nukes Taku
in the chat or does he say it knocks
Taku Remy no next taka
it's yelled out of him yeah I love all
my favorite youtubers yeah yeah he's
great like he does um you know satirical
anime review goddess they're kind of a
trailers he does like for kids trailers
for anime reviews like a bridge series
in a hilarious way definitely huh
excellent same lost pause war a peacock
fit for 1 million some yeah and by the
way Knox Taku made a video about lost
balls like a sarcastic youtuber trailer
and lots of us made a video about that
video
responding to the video so that was
hilarious oh the animated Kenichi
cosplay for me 100% has to be done one
day explain probably good idea
I want to wear a kekkaishi outfit from
Naruto that'd be cool
you definitely see a couple Kakashi's at
our convention oh yeah a lot of tons of
narutards everywhere but the worst the
worst people are like who cosplay is
like Superman and Batman and [ __ ] on
like hawks it's an anime convention dude
going back to comic-con dude
yeah and comic-con you can wear anything
what an enemy convention you have to
wear anime related stuff I hope I also
see you a someone cosplaying as Reese
I'm gonna actually ask it out like hey
baby are you like hey baby are you the
real reason I'm looking for it could be
a brother it could be a trap oh are you
finally the real one I've been looking
for I guarantee I wanted handful of them
for conventions guys there will be traps
though if summer August others what
reward oh wait NOK stock who says that
he's gonna have a part 2 coming soon
with the lost pause video so we gotta
check that [ __ ] out that's a bit nuts
knuckle on here for a guest one week
even though he got to his face sure I've
never seen his face he doesn't show it I
think like in one video he had like a
Tokyo ghoul mask on and it's the only
time you think review of themself oh
he's still waiting for that watermill
face for real hmm I want to see cyanides
face what does he look like I'm pretty
sure you already know that bro don't you
and you're hiding it from us I'll take
any of us know maybe I'm right here if I
give you the only person I I know I'm
probably uproar Anna Mikey probably
already know what cyanide looks like I
actually don't oh really I don't he's a
mystery he's an enigma no one knows him
Maya shoutout to Amelia and Luna in the
chat and someone said something I wanted
to comment on oh yeah
anime dude mentioned it Mac is going to
be cosplaying as run from re0
yes at anime North 2017 so yeah there
definitely traps guys Mac will be one of
them the mustache will probably give it
away though but sometimes there is no
mustache so he took it off
yes trim it mob King says he's been
waiting all day for this well that's
good to hear bro now you put all this
pressure on me to actually be
entertaining it [ __ ] I don't know if I
can handle that
Briggs can we handle that of course I
think he was waiting for what they call
the debate if you commented on my
channel by talking about the debate and
stuff I never talk to one piece yeah oh
yeah which is waited for we had to
postpone it for next week so that we can
get another youtuber on this uh miss art
who is a huge Naruto fan
so we she couldn't do this week but she
can do next next week so we're
postponing it next week we're gonna have
miss art and Lotus versus Briggs and too
spooky and it's not hugging direct epic
showdown of course Briggs you're like
the [ __ ] / a guy who does anime facts
of course you're gonna be a freakin boss
at one piece
Luna Lunas or he knows everything
Luna asks what do you think Anna Mac
would look like as Hatsune Miku and I
think that I would look like on boos
worst nightmare are you gonna vlog it
both of you
yeah we're gonna do some vlogging we're
under szilágyi yeah I haven't decided
yet I will um I'll definitely watch it
when you vlog it's I can see everyone's
cosplay are you both going to cosplay or
just gonna go over there like like noobs
doing nothing go to Spooky's in the chod
he heard he heard his name being called
and he's like it's gonna happen man is
gonna happen
dude next week next week it's on by the
way for cosplay I will probably cosplay
for a skit
then we're gonna shoot there for a
comedy skit but not like as a character
but as a diff as a character for that
video oh yeah I should cosplay is
Kenichi
and buy an outfit before it's time to go
Briggs what people do is they cosplay as
everything's on different days so you
could do that like cosplays one one
thing on Saturday one thing on Sunday a
lot of effort I would call going for two
days I went to all of with all three
days and one for the weekend
yeah I'm probably gonna probably go for
a bit on Friday because I think Friday
is not a full date right brick no II
like starts like five or six yeah so
we're gonna go drop by there and then
we're gonna be there all day Saturday
all day Sunday
yeah man it's only once a year so you
got a goal you got a support anime North
it is the second biggest convention in
North America for anime the biggest
convention in Canada and just a great
time it's like it's organized by fans
it's not like my big corporation or
anything like that it's not just for
profit it's for fun so they build a
great community around it I wish I could
go if I live in America well you got out
you gotta get a plane ticket bro
no I get a plane ticket just to go in an
Emmy convention for two days and come
back [ __ ] no but I'd love to eight you
in real life though yeah I mean really
one that that's what I want to do I want
to meet you Reagan real in real life
have you met Briggs in real life not yet
I will add anime north nice cuz we live
pretty close I was like shoul Briggs you
want me to come to your house what's up
and he's just like mash it that down but
he was like what it's like we will do
will do will do the collaboration at
anime North yeah yeah it's like yeah man
it there's time though you know don't
rush it though Russia I'm the only one
who lives far away from everyone
Rick is asking why the thumbnail for
this had the black credit guy it's do
technically not a thumbnail just like a
capture of the stream black critic i was
in here earlier but then he dropped out
because i think he was having problems
he was on his phone and i think he
dropped out because of his connection if
he comes back in that'll be cool
well yeah he was here when we started
when we started it was just me and him
oh yeah Liz delayed I spent 40 minutes
trying to create a new set up for live
streaming and I had to go back to the
shitty one cuz I couldn't it wasn't work
it out
and yet are you upset but next time
it'll be ready in terms of the vlogs for
enemy North bricks like I think we're
definitely to have like a blog after the
whole thing kind of like actual edited
vlog like hopefully good vlog for the
whole thing but I was taking also making
just like quick vlogs um every day as
we're there if we're able to actually
don't edit and everything if not we
might just post them on like Twitter
like Twitter video Facebook video so in
the description you can find our Twitter
and Briggs and recon also on Twitter's
of course I don't have them linked in
the description though but you could
reorder a channel they have a link so on
Twitter we'll be posting pictures we
also Instagram so Twitter Instagram and
Facebook we're gonna be posting pictures
and hopefully some short videos but
we're also going to have vlogs on the
channel it's just probably going to take
a few days for us to actually edit the
vlogs and put them on the channel to
make them look presentable there yeah
good other people gonna come and meet
you like your fans and subscribers well
yeah if whoever wants to come and meet
us there if you're going to I don't know
how many people are actually in Canada
go enjoy my North that kind of stuff but
we're not we're gonna be for sure
meeting up with Briggs Mac vector
Maximus
so there's gonna be a few of us for sure
alright school we're gonna be a Croom
and we're gonna be a frickin Shemp aqua
lions over there by the way did you tell
the manager over there to like get you
like I don't know a place you can sign
autographs people coming to see you like
your gun man me and PewDiePie yeah we're
on that left only on that level bit Mike
whatever we have Oh be like what do you
go there oh they're like how do you do
it though like what do you have to do in
order to get your own stand and sign
autographs for people like what do you
have to be big enough for them to invite
you I think that's the only way it works
oh when you're like hundreds of
thousands of subscribers then they
notice you and they're like oh man we
want you cuz you're gonna draw and
people to come to the car we're
definitely not at that level yet
although we do have some lovely fans
love you guys and ladies and ladies and
I bet you have more money on their iPad
back dubs
you have my day long
or males subscribing an email but 80% on
my end like I think like a third of ours
or female if we made more videos on like
different types of animatic I'm making
all shonan's with is like a demographic
for guys right I'm making too many top
tens with male care cuz I probably
switched to female so for bad I just
probably done like sometimes you get
their likeness go for it that's olive
you know protagonist then all them
female girls come and subscribe to my
channel eggs like hell yeah not if you
talk to female protagonists with a young
boob thumbnail I'd come to it you're
getting males yeah glad Rick but Rick
says that he wants to definitely see
some logs on here on the channel you
will see it you will see it it just
might not be the day of we might take a
few days for us to upload it but
definitely you will see some logs so
stay tuned for that and yeah by the way
on my like Yuri a nice video that I
didn't use video for yuria dice it's
like 88% female audience so if you wanna
draw in a female crowd yuria nice videos
are a good way to go I'll tell you that
right now I'm gonna stick with one piece
I check I checked a statistic the other
day I was like 88% female what the [ __ ]
no I don't even mind as Eragon not even
Anna Mac after dark which I was
explained to get a huge female audience
he did not get 90% c'mon it's surprising
oh no no no no knock stock we did a
sarcastic trailer for Yuri nice and he
says he also did also got a whole bunch
of girls in there it's like yeah
although a lot of the fans we realized
don't have much of a sense of humor so
Knox tell us did you get a bunch of hate
for that video cuz yeah the song
sometimes the fans of your eyes don't
have a sense of give me like what this
isn't just glowing praise or you're
gonna ice hit that dislike button baby
Luna's like there might be less of us
females but we will have Anna Mac more
that's what I like to hear Luna that's
what I like to hear
it's not to wonder the female fans are
the most dedicated yeah it's not so I
got right quality guys but yes so so far
so much so far you know what happened to
Mackel not showing up what happened to
Brynn dropping by where cyanide blizzard
what's going on guys what's going on I
get hit Tony was having technical issues
but yeah see yeah see Briggs
recon without you I can third I'm right
here
yeah I know but without you what would I
be doing I would be by myself just
crying just crying him yeah I came in as
only Tony I was so surprised she's the
one person that said he wasn't gonna
come I know I know
well see this is the thing this is the
thing I I like make these rank up a
right livestreams weekly so I have to
take responsibility other people like
you know you know whatever we show up we
don't show up but I have to be here I
have to take responsibility one week it
was just me and cyanide the whole time
cuz no one [ __ ] showed that wasn't
cool that wasn't cool
so to ravage and by the way we had a
cool stream on Briggs's channel for the
seven deadly sins back on Tuesday that
went well and it was a fun time and we
had quite a few people watching after
the fact breaks I noticed that so that
was cool
yeah people saw like thumbnail season
two just had to find out about it man
yeah your clickbait game is getting but
actually in pretty good Clickbank right
there Thanks well done I've been meaning
to change that thumbnail I literally
just googled $0.78 season two to be
honest every other thumbs on my on my
channels like made by me that I just
clicked like cool season to play I was
scrambling to get one up for the stream
or I thought you actually made that
because it looks like Nick your other
thumbnails kind of style wise yeah
that's why I like Oh perfect yeah I hear
kids in the back end no I think it's
just recon watching like a
Marya no I'm just watching some lolly
should admit it no why would you think
that's lolly she does it sounds like a
child like a [ __ ] man no no that you do
not know it's just something with is
just somebody using like a voice changer
don't worry about definitely I
definitely don't have a lolly fetish or
anything why would I do that
well I certainly don't my dude that is
not my cup of tea at all by the way
anime world is asking if I've seen the
new Code Geass picture I assume you mean
the one with Colin and c2 if you mean
that one that was post on our discord so
I did see that when Luna says she
watched the brick stream because I was
there so that's good that's good
Lunas following Anna Mac wherever he
goes so you didn't watch it for me here
I watched it for you great thanks man
I commented on brick stream after file
like Briggs great guests because his
guests were goes on and Mees oh I got a
good laugh like that yeah I always make
mice I always laugh at my own jokes I
feel like that is an important thing to
do course always animal world are you in
our discord if you're in the disc or
message me and send me the picture you
mean if not just link it here and let's
link it in the chat cuz I would like to
see what you're talking about I'm not
sure
ANBU says he watch the stream because of
goes on that's not so animated coming
through watching it for me I think anime
dude watch it for all of us animate dude
knows then when goes in Anna Mac and
Briggs get together [ __ ] goes down [ __ ]
goes down tis true and also like I like
how to spook you always drops in on all
the streams he dropped it on that stream
you dropped
this dream is a he's a great dude he's
just like you know supporting the cause
support the community yeah I just don't
fun just keeping to yourself on YouTube
like I'll do making YouTube videos is a
great time but getting involved in the
community just makes it a better
experience no yeah I know like I know
there's so many youtubers out there who
just make videos you know only top 10
lists or whatever just just to get views
they don't engage in or answer their
comments they don't do anything like
that
well like to me that's no fun like why
if you're producing content that people
actually appreciate and they want to
talk to you about it why wouldn't you
want to you know listen to what they
have to say talk to them improve your
content paid based on their feedback I
find that a lot of my videos were
approved because I was listening to
people they're like oh you missed this
or what about next to you you could do
that and I'm like oh yeah that's a great
idea
so actually a videos I'm working on
right now related to code geass came the
idea came completely as a from a comment
on one of our videos because I I
wouldn't even thought of it without that
because I'm not informed in that
specific area so I was like man that's
great so yeah absolutely you should read
your comments respond to all the ones
you can because it's always the better
experience but in terms of conventions
anything else you guys can think of that
are it's like an important tip by the
way we're good shoes yes yes true
because you're going to be walking
around conventions are usually in big
areas plazas convention centers so
you're gonna be walking from one area to
the other so don't wear high heels and
stuff unless you're really you know I
don't care how committed you are to your
cosplay if you're in high heels you're
gonna you're gonna have a bad time but
um by the way can we just thank the
creators of killa kill because after
that show came on in 2012 I believe the
conventions the cosplays of the
conventions were just thank you guys
thank you someone supplement some
recommendations on brutal any I might
would talk down on that but what do you
think of my next top ten should be I'm
thinking of top 10 anime romance with
cool male lead gopher dude I'm sticking
with a top 10 female protagonists a
knife
mm ah the thing is I I don't really want
to do females I mean I'd I'll get I'll
get views there's not much females you
know Oh couple this top-10 most badass
female characters and we I'm gonna
missus put an obvious number one it's
over I already I already had that idea
breaks but was too lazy to make it so go
ahead by the way uh I'm sure that I want
to be noted that anime recut said I
don't want to do females quote uh I
don't want to do females 2017
okay how about the night I do a book no
no I do come I do come back uh I do
include females within my top tens of
course but I just don't like
specifically put the title as top ten
badass female or anything well I have
see any problem that if anything that's
more likely for me to click I don't want
to see a bunch of Kirito [ __ ] but I
don't put Kirito [ __ ] why would I do
that
you love Kirito yeah I know he's my
favorite male character but I don't I
don't really give a [ __ ] what everyone
says I really give your [ __ ] but he's
the worst a little little cooler should
I'm the worst never weren't you the best
man to me he is but he liked him better
than [ __ ] deku but he's nowhere near
the best guys better than ji Lee
debatable he's better than dead good by
the way
Lawrence Lawrence asks when we're gonna
do a watch comment what we're gonna do
is gonna watch it on Saturday at 12 noon
Eastern Standard Time and we're gonna
we're planning on goes n is figuring out
how to put it on screen so that you guys
can see us and cold mint at the same
time and I think he's figured it out
already so that would be cool so that
way you have a timer you just see it all
right there on the screen as we're
watching it so I think he's managed to
figure that out and that should be a lot
of fun so be tune in for that
on Saturday um by the way can we talk a
bit about like I was hoping Brin would
be here and all the other fanboys and
fangirls whether or not so breaks and
recon I will take it out on you did you
watch the latest episode of my
beer academia us me yeah yeah I did
oh sorry sorry yes I have watch the
latest episode boku no hero yes
Briggs yeah for I don't remember what
happened but yeah you don't tell me what
happened
I thought okie literally beat someone by
completely freezing him in the melting
him with the other hand and deck we even
won so probably next episode we're gonna
see them both fight which is also
everybody next up is deck over here okay
which is what everybody is waiting for
its most likely listen to this listen to
this but you see the dog lick one that
was the biggest [ __ ] he just oh my
god like why do people how can people
tolerate this troll like he is being his
brain is being controlled by the
brainwash work and then all of a sudden
I don't know where all I broke through
it guys like he his power should not be
called all for nothing all for one it
should be called deus ex machina because
that's what it is it's like oh my no
matter what happens his power will
always change the rules will change
something will happen so that he comes
out on top what [ __ ] what terrible
writing Wow
a lot of pretty [ __ ] i actually gets
worse and worse I don't understand how
people can enjoy I really do
it's gonna get better and better but I
could agree with you in that moment the
whole thing is that he's supposed to do
it like any forces enough to break the
mind-control but just kind of like how
was he able to do it I don't know the
reasoning with like once you saw all the
people for one for all a like me I'm
snapping for a second to be able to move
like or the one for all activated his
ability but then he moved his finger or
something I don't know it's pretty
[ __ ] I agree yeah but it wasn't
supposed to be able to move his finger
anyways so yeah like that's the thing
like he started off as a guy with no
quirk right which was interesting and
then he went from that as like an
underdog to being the most overpowered
without any you know reason and it's
just it's just ridiculous like no I
don't like the fact that total DS dad
literally is just you only have one
thing to do
surpass all lights powers I don't care
what you do you know [ __ ] big this
guy I want to be at the top it's like
his dad just is trying to motivate him
to become the best and better than all
might but the question is does total I
think total key has two powers the power
of his dad in the power of his mom being
Ice and Fire correct yeah because that
way that's what he did with one hand he
frozen with the other end he melted the
ice Lee and that's when I thought and I
actually thought that was a cool part of
the episode where they introduced the
fact that some people marry for quirks
so like before people would marry for
money marry you know rich families would
marry each other
for money and power in that world
they're marrying for quirks so totally
Rocky's father married his mother
because their quirks together would work
well who wanted to create a more
powerful offspring which I think it's a
cool idea and I think totally is an
interesting character because of that
whole dynamic with his father me it's
been done to death but still it's pretty
interesting because he's like rebelling
against his father by only using the one
side his mother side but again the focus
is not on him the focuses on deku and
deku the whole thing is just such BS
that I just can't get into like I hate
watch that show because I still watch it
but I hate watch it I I gotta actually I
haven't even talked to goals and yet
about how he feels about this let me see
if easier goes in why didn't you have
him join us on stream there's no one
here today he's gonna go he's actually
gonna go get him that's a little [ __ ]
no I still love my hair academia it's
not absolutely amazing and just some
moments I agree without a man you saying
you don't like it
no I I just said I absolutely love it I
just like I could see the flaws you know
what I mean Colin's got drop by you just
has to put on pants all right is the
second season not as good as the pageant
which which season do you think is
better the first or the second well we
haven't seen it all right Jimmy 24
episodes are gonna go a lot into like
more with the villains later on and
that's what I'm looking forward to it's
gonna continue over on the [ __ ] new
seasonal anime I'm gonna have to react
to extra anime now great hmm yeah it's
left over
jirô the hero has a good comment he's
like Biscay deck whose power is called
main character power and it's hashtag
win no matter what
yeah I guess uh you know power should
not be called one for all it should be
called win no matter what or deus ex
machina or whatever you want to call it
and that anime snob actually made a
video where he talked about the problem
with my ear academia is that dec who is
the center of that enemy everything
revolves around him so everything is
kind of everyone else is dependent on
him and there's a lot of deus ex machina
because of him so yeah that's the videos
i definitely agree with there's goals in
right here who's that gun ants on and
everything you put on his mask by the
way we usually just stream without pants
Briggs knows yeah saying why would even
bother good that's Christ we're talking
about my year academia yeah what are
your how do you feel about the last
episode I am refresh my memory because I
washed out when it came out so ok so
basically uh Deku was finding that [ __ ]
oh guy and he was controlling him with
his quirk and then he just deus ex
machina to breaking the eye this is this
what anime doesn't get like every every
shoulder has it is not xbox but it's in
every episode for [ __ ] Deku like
he'll every I'm sorry every girl has it
and even in some deadly sins right
malleolus has it's like full demon mode
or whatever that is and in the lantern
Last Airbender it's Avatar state like
every Shonen has some kind of superpower
that they can use and times like that so
it's not there's five good shows that
use it right that's one thing another
thing is Lex like what's what's wrong
with it they even explain it how like
all of the people inside the one for all
are using kind of I think up their own
accord kind things you understand what
happened we're gonna find some way to
explain every single situation what do
you mean like let's he gonna loose like
so they just gonna lose right on that
yeah that would have been [ __ ] no
nickel what he didn't follow kit why
Swiss friend he did the exact opposite
rap and he should have loved and by the
way how boring without episode Bebo yeah
all of a sudden he's like I'll follow
the advice my friend and he just pushes
an on the ring well yeah [ __ ] that's the
way to go
what armor-like I'm sick of the blood
armor natural and also if you look at
like malleolus like he doesn't go full
demon mode for nothing to win some
[ __ ] tournament he goes full demon
mode with like Elizabeth is a mortal
danger or he's upset like because
someone is in mortal danger becos like
problems are different obviously because
he's it's more like our time period if
we have like magic powers all of a
sudden so he has much more realistic
problems that combine with the super
powers so it's not like let's save the
world right now it's more like hey I'm
in school and I want to do well so it
has different different motivations
confident but I'm sure by the end of it
there's nothing gonna be a lot of like
we're out saving to be done and by the
way unity animate the fan of my hair up
being agrees with me that Deku should
have lost that one to learn a fine
delicious what about a different way
like that that fight to me I don't know
you guys thought it was definite like
not one of the most exciting moments in
the show but are you hype for Todoroki
versus Nek minnit yeah to Spooky's like
just wait for that commercial Todoroki
he's like des please like guys just
please just please do it show guys
yeah it's gonna be now that I actually
agree I hope that's like a one piece
argument guys just wait for manga
chapter mm it's gonna be great it's got
a you got to love it to be there like
you didn't watch any one piece yeah I
ate a lot like I was probably a few
episodes like way back today yeah like I
can't but that's the guy that's going to
be a moderator I haven't really watched
our door one piece I'm so excited
especially since we found people
actually want to defend wholeheartedly
narcho and people want to defend one
piece it's gonna be sick I'm so excited
to watch it I can't I cannot wait for
next week are you gonna lose brigs know
if we take well I think we have an
advantage here because one piece is so
much better to be honest we all haven't
started already like I just think of so
many things that pissed me off about
Naruto guy just didn't feel about one
piece look there's all the different
notes but we all probably know how the
results are gonna be remember the
Emilien
is REM oh yes that yeah where you guys
got on but you wouldn't admit you got
old like I believe that you died in the
barn a shock we did not get on because
we kept on talking over and over again
so it was like I'm wearing I'll talk
about episode 18 over and over again but
we were on TV ah nothing like a lot of
reasons you don't talk about just 24
episodes yeah but yeah yeah what episode
18 like that should be like a meme it's
like well you make a good point sir but
episode 18 yeah sometimes the best clues
are allocated one I think you're gonna
do episode this for one piece in episode
that for Naruto like do you remember
episode boom of Naruto or one piece you
remember later century 42 of one yes we
have some we have some hype in the chair
there's a few people that Luna is saying
Naruto will win mob king is saying
Naruto for life so we got some hype
going on for this debate yo yeah not our
toll like I really like the beginning um
later on
I kind of think it fell off me but one
piece like I didn't get a fair chance
because some of the character designs
were so crazy when I was watching
doesn't kid out feel like oh man first a
short guy and then the octopus lookin
dude and I was just like no I can't get
into these character vein you just got a
trigger rich or not boy not knowing your
names of my heart know like bells for me
like probably if I wash it again I are
long and Hatchery but at that time I'm
just like this I decide like you have
all these Dragon Ball Z cool villains
design [ __ ] and then you have this with
your super which oh shoot yeah before
super which and this just looked kind of
lazy to me but I should focus on the
story not the like and by the way
Reservoir Warrior is saying one piece so
you know he's in for one piece you know
creep Ellen will be in for one piece so
it's gonna be animate is conflicted cuz
he loves both Vega when are they gonna
find one to one piece bro where are they
gonna find it where when or oh and oh I
don't know next couple decades or so
where we got Knox Taku and 2spooky
chatting with us
so some quality ass youtuber
chatting with us on rank of a shout-out
to those guys again
well I just watched no whole reacts to
knocks taku this video it was a little
people I'm gonna have to go now because
I've got College tomorrow but I enjoyed
the street thanks for thanks everyone
for all the advice on the enemy
conventions I appreciate thank you for
logging in as havoc rehung appreciate it
and also NME North Briggs can we agree
to when we see someone cosplaying as my
hero academia star ranting at them about
their cool episode 4 bro Bluebook yo Co
recon and yeah I think I'm wrong
personally I if Todoroki doesn't beat
Deku I'm that's gonna be such BS like
they're gonna come up with such BS way
odd like to for him to wear my get out
of here it's not about weathering when
it's about Hollywood that yeah but they
didn't establish him as a cool enough
character as an adequate enough
character to be winning at this time so
that's a failing of the writing well I
think the point is that he's constantly
challenging his comfort zone and
actually leveling up every time he's
fighting and what he needs to so I feel
like nothing for anything because I know
what happened but it's gonna be a good
fight guys yeah that's that's hard for
me like what are watching attack on
Titan and then right you acting I'm like
I don't know is it I don't know not just
job like bros everyone a [ __ ] title I
don't know man oh yeah have you looked
like a kind of analogous Mysterio oh so
I pray I'm enjoying my hero academia I
don't I'm not expect me to be like on a
colony now which I heard was mentioned
earlier like I'm not expecting it to be
uh work of Tolstoy but I think it's good
for what it is it's a fun show I want to
ask nuts talking who we think did a win
one piece versus Naruto he could answer
in the chat well I wonder though cuz
it's gonna also depend on how good you
are as out of the debater and let's
we'll see man because I don't know MIT I
feel like Briggs and
and 2spooky you can't find bigger one
piece fans like bigger better
representatives for one piece they had
Briggs it's any highschool care very
confident from what I hear I feel like
they're they're just worried that I'll
be over too quick yeah yeah but like
we're gonna have miss art and she's a
huge fan of Naruto she's known on
YouTube for being a big fan of Naruto so
I feel like she's gonna give a run for
their money and she's gonna do it in a
very nice and polite way cuz she's got
what about Lotus how dedicated he the
chief fan of Naruto and he's especially
not a fan one piece or he's like more or
not afraid of one piece of metal Naruto
but like he'll he'll come through
that's that I don't see that a lot
people who are adamantly not fans of one
piece I would argue for Naruto that's
pretty pretty rare he read like the
first hundred chapters or something like
he hadn't even got to Grand Line yet but
uh what what what crazed maniac yo he's
only a hundred that's it what a [ __ ]
haha
with all this good because you can still
make the argument it's like if this if
this manga and diamond chapters didn't
draw me in there's something wrong with
it and here's what right so you don't
have to watch the whole thing but if you
didn't watch the whole thing or you
didn't read the whole thing you should
be able to argue why you why you didn't
grip you enough to continue watching so
you can say you can't prevent an
argument why he dropped it wait let's go
beyond character designs because that
was his one point in oh damn he started
to hurry I got alone man but but that's
what I heard I heard on Troy how you
racially your fish mad bro those fish
that are so cool
I heard of from people that he's the guy
who created one piece is considered like
the worst illustrator of the big three
but at the same time considered the best
writer of the big three
I could I could avert that I think his
back I think his background illustration
is on par if not better but he does very
unique character designs in terms of I
got you the villains their faces like
you just big heads and stuff and people
just find it weird I personally have
come to love it but I feel like
character design make that's personal
preference bro pray like one like one
argument more talk about what that's a
cool
herb I don't know if any own commented
on it yet but it looks cool thank thanks
bro
hmm yeah you know all right man good bye
but no it's good is gonna be cool yeah
we're gonna be meeting Briggs man on can
read online okay we gotta take off
we gotta take a anime youtubers photo
it's like all of us on oh yeah yeah oh
we're gonna hang out the whole time and
we gotta like a crew we're gonna have a
squad we're gonna squat up assess what
up bro and try not to go bankrupt yeah
we don't want to feel old me and [ __ ] so
there's got like all of us to stick it
together oh we got to make sure math a
lot is not spending his money cuz last
time like it's probably where any
shadows like a we got to put him on
control when my buddy's is coming and he
always buy swords so here I'm already
gonna buy a sword oh it's so hard for me
to like walk by swords not by oh my god
I don't care what it is is a sort of
online sword is like a different sword
like when I see a sword and let's not
get Freudian here but like I want to buy
it back oh I love oh so many people in
the chatter just like going out at about
an hour joining one B's it's great yeah
that's that folds well for everybody I
gotta be fun it's gonna be fun I want
you the argument what I was saying
before is I want you the arguments go
more to storytelling and like structure
and something value and what they can
would you have you freaking bring it
that's not going there you tell it like
the character design well like you know
what 20 with a bunch of chatter saying
Animax of Titan right so we'll be
baseball fights a grass I don't [ __ ]
die what is this what the [ __ ]
no but tight um attack on Tiny's
interesting because I'm just reading the
manga now by the way Aaron is a [ __ ]
badass
I don't care what anyone says from the
beginning he was always the opposite
Jack who's not crying like a [ __ ] is
like we're gonna [ __ ] do this not
protect humanity someone else is like
man I don't have new soldiers you take
some rocket trucks in strange like you
[ __ ] traitor
you [ __ ] trees people risk you sob
and I'm rereading it to ya right now and
what I was going to say is that if you
look at the design of the actual Titans
they're very like strangely designed
very human well yeah so make sure like
it's it's almost like a separate style
like they look awkward and weird they
pull it off yeah but it's like drawn
well but purposely looks not
proportional and weird but it's like
it's let's say planned chaos like
constructed weirdness so maybe that's
what the one piece guy was going for -
let's look like for example mob psycho
or like one he has like they didn't they
animated mob psycho when like the
original art style type of thing are
very similar because he just had a
unique thing and some people were just
like I can't watch it because of it but
if you actually watch the story it was a
great anime and you get I became a fan
of that art style and that's what I've
come to be a fan on for one piece like
I've been watching and reading one piece
for like eight or nine years now
it's like you become a fan of the art
style the whole life brick that's so
cool and yeah it's it's cool how
everyone thought like one style was
horrible and that it needed to be kind
of modernized by professional
illustrator and stuff like that but yeah
that's cool if if they did it in the
original way and then people start
liking that I got so cool cuz no one
would let it be forced that he's like
talented like rawr right but that's cool
that he pulls it off and be black she
respond to it and by the way can I knock
was saying in the chat that he's got
some rap coming up rap battle look oh my
god
we're actually at some rap stuff - dude
we're doing some rap stuff
- I will battle rap all in a time there
isn't enough rap stuff in the anime
community for me I will battle rap
anyone anime man anime snob anime dude
anime I wanna battle anyone do you well
battle me on our web it's gonna be good
you won't bow me and rap you too scared
man well like are we freestyling like
what's going on no no that's right
nothing rhymes yeah like I I can rhyme
but at the same time I know nothing
about like
bars and so it'll probably sound not as
good because I could just drive it but
then again I would I probably look for
silent eyes and the excuses begin guys
excuses but not known I was like oh the
flow I can't do it because it was built
of fluoride
yeah you think that you didn't have the
full because you know why because when
we when we sing colors I crushed you
know what bow down if you want to do it
you gonna regret this bro you're gonna
regret this
ah Luna I hope tell us a [ __ ] typo in
the chat what don't say it just don't
even say it
I hope she means rap oh man don't you
say yes yes yeah
don't sit oh that's funny
wait no I will definitely win but it's
gonna be fun yes I'm definitely gonna do
some rap related skit for anime north
that's coming up and I want to do some
more anime rap the related stuff and no
rap battles would be fun - I know Joey
the enemy has done some rap battles yeah
in the ass like well versus like
Australian accent
look guys pretty good he's pretty good
no I think was it Elvis and white or was
it blue horses L I think I was a loser
so well oh it might have been yeah I
forget now thank you
your animal knowledge needs some yeah
well it was like quality today than like
three years ago
true fans bro true fan right here
the girls like jibun yes and bash once
on a tie once a discord rap battle I'll
be interesting - well yeah sounds like
fun man this con is going to be great to
next week's debate is gonna be great
naruto vs one piece
stay tuned for that of course every
Thursday 5:00 p.m. Eastern Standard Time
is when we do the red coat okay Briggs
anything else you want to say before we
call it a day and start an undeniable
ending teachers gonna win next week yeah
I don't want to take too much away free
I know you're prepping hard for next
week
I don't need a prep I was born ready
bring notes great milk like anime yeah I
got notes man Emilia versus yo you know
Briggs you know those those were good we
know we yeah okay take this in I think
we did an amazing job considering I
think RAM had the advantage in this
scenario next week one piece has the
advantage and I'm still gonna do an
amazing job so like they don't have a
chance
yeah like there was a bunch of people
who before are the Bayon Ren versus of
Emilia didn't even give Amelia a second
thought and after the main direct man
you know what if they were neutral field
be like y'all I'm not even really I love
you like man I totally get what you guys
are saying so yeah we were the underdogs
but unlike deku we used our actual
intelligence to win not just pure lock
and quad convenience question though how
how did you decide who won well we
decided we want some kind of system or
like okay fair we uh we asked the chat
and we found something like what you
decide you decide so we asked what that
it was a tie but then yeah we have like
a poll that was a tie like in the chat
but we obviously we think we want they
think they want but we know it's all
about the poll like but the whole thing
or the figure there's people that were
saying Oh Ren wins before the poll
before it even started like and it's
like I think they were to change their
opinion oh I guess it for being like
crazy about it but at the same time
excuses man excuses they don't can be
tied though we tied but think about the
crunchy roll thing and that's a
representation of how polls work I don't
want to be part of them the quencher
Awards yeah yeah I don't know naruto vs
Wimpy's I feel like both have huge fan
bases so doing a poll and that would be
more fair with Amelia she was such an
underdog that like it's like doing a
poll is not even fair because people
made up their minds way before it yeah I
ran to see my tweet I was like I've been
while watch the first eight episodes of
a 3-0 and then drop it haha yeah it's
true man it's true yep like these guys
do just free watch episode 18 twelve
times and like well yeah but uh yeah
Briggs let us know who you are and what
you do before we call this a baby by the
way Briggs's link is in the description
along with a bunch of other people that
didn't show up today but anna-marie
here Tony was here briefly their links
are actually Tony might not be in the
description because he said he wasn't
going to show up in any control but
thank you for that but of course his tag
is black credit guy so you can find him
and yeah Briggs yeah I'm Briggs from all
the anime make a lot of fact videos on
like it's interesting things about
characters in series lately I've been
doing a lot of like explain videos
exclaiming cool concepts like one for
all in are all for one one for all in my
hero academia and just cool things like
abilities and $0.70 and stuff like that
yeah but that's about it
I've been trying to chunk it up ooh
sarcastic trailer for my hero academia
that I really thoroughly enjoyed knowing
my views on the whole thing so yeah good
job
Briggs inspired by nuts tacos actually
yeah yeah knocks taco neck stuck was a
good quality youtuber I like it and also
we had we had someone mentioned in the
chat killer read he's like I can and
will write entire essays as to why
Naruto sucks balls so I loved it I loved
it man the hype is real for next week
guys stay tuned for that and thank you
for showing up this week as always I
always think it's crazy that we have a
you know an active base of people that
come and watch these rent cafes and hang
out with us every week it's final I'm
gonna go a bit into this Court now to
hang out I'm just wrapping up go zet
yeah why I say bye thank you guys for
showing up for hanging out with us as
usual stay tuned for next week it's
gonna be crazy
and of course Saturday streams we're
gonna be doing those yeah the other day
it's gonna be cool
and we have to set up we have some huge
projects in the works an attack on Titan
big video and a Code Geass video are in
the works on our end so stay tuned for
that everybody thank you again for
joining us thank you Briggs for being
our guest and until next time I think he
goes over so I'll see is space cowboys
bang shin PACU